[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7-8 journal
nous sommes le mercredi 19 février
voici les titres qui seront développés
dans cette édition
nous nous intéresserons au quotidien des
seniors avec le vieillissement de la
population le raccompagnement est un
réel enjeu est d entreprise et offrent
leurs services dans un objectif de
maintien à domicile
de son côté le programme silver
fourchette sensibilise sur la
dénutrition des seniors sophie touzet
men chef de projet pour cette initiative
dans les yvelines sera en plateau dans
un peu moins d'un mois le premier tour
des élections municipales la campagne
bat son plein nous irons attrape-tout le
maire sortant guy malandain organisé une
réunion publique
nous prendrons également à la direction
de coignières pour en savoir plus sur
les enjeux de ce scrutin
le jeune héros de bd gallo-romain alix
est à l'honneur à l'espace richaud à
versailles une grande rétrospective lui
est consacrée jusqu'au 19 avril des
planches et des dessins originaux
retrace son épopée
c'est à découvrir à la fin de cette
édition mais avant de développer tous
ces titres et cette information à
pratiquer payer sa taxe d'habitation et
ses frais hospitaliers ou encore ses
factures de crèches directement chez son
buraliste et bien ce sera possible dans
les yvelines à partir du 24 février une
première phase de test a lieu dans dix
départements avant un déploiement total
du dispositif prévu cet été pour chaque
transaction effectuée le buraliste
touchera 1 euro 80 de la part de l'état
le but est d'accueillir les
contribuables au plus proche de leur
domicile
et justement parmi le public visé par ce
dispositif les seniors selon l'insee les
plus de 85 ans était un million quatre
cent mille en 2018
il devrait être d'ailleurs 5 millions en
2060 le vieillissement de la population
et l'accompagnement est des seniors est
un réel enjeu et dans un objectif
justement de maintien à domicile des
entreprises étendent leurs activités
habituelles
marylène aya pichenot a suivi l'une
d'elles à plaisir une fois par semaine
coraline se rend chez madame jaussaud
oui
la femme de ménage elle est employée par
une agence spécialisée dans l'aide à
domicile ici sa mission est de faire le
ménage pendant deux heures chaque
mercredi matin j'ai vu vd pour l'heure
je suis obligé parce que je ne peux pas
tout faire
veuillez pour eux et mauvais des bras
pour effet plus de difficultés mais plus
qu'une aide ménagère coraline se fait
aussi régulièrement offrir le café par
madame jaussaud elle le fait de passer
du temps avec eux de pouvoir aussi aux
portes de nos vies on est vraiment un
lien avec les clients en plus du fait
qu'on leur apporte notre aide pour le
ménage si madame jaussaud est encore en
pleine forme pour faire sa cuisine et
ses courses ce n'est pas toujours le cas
des seniors qui peuvent tendre vers une
perte d'autonomie
forte de ce constat et du lien que nous
leur quarantaine de salariés avec leurs
clients seniors lagence plaisir was a
décidé d'étendre l'activité dettes
ménagères un réel accompagnement en
quatre axes alliés saveurs et nutrition
cultiver les liens intergénérationnels
prévenir les risques domestiques
enfin travailler sa mémoire et on est
vraiment sur une prise en charge globale
mais toujours en faisant ensemble et pas
à la place de puisque l'idée est
naturellement de préserver l'autonomie
des personnes âgées et aime bien qu'il
soit en perte d'autonomie progressive et
donc de les maintenir à leur domicile ce
qui est leur souhait l'agent selon cette
nouvelle prestation après deux ans
d'installation à plaisir et interviendra
également sur les communes de vul
prouver les clayes-sous-bois une manière
aussi de lutter contre l' isolement
selon le ministère des solidarités de la
santé 50 % des personnes de plus de 75
ans n'ont plus de réseau amical actifs
portrait à présent à d'un guyancourt
toit de 33 ans après une reconversion
dans la menuiserie kevin martin souhaite
lancer son activité il s'agit d'un
atelier de menuiserie itinérante
reportage de nicolas landry
on va aller travailler en fait là dessus
je vais m'en servir de base pour
imprimer mes cartes de visite à l'aide
de l'imprimante laser
c'est au skylight de la verrière qui
nourrit son projet sa passion menuisier
de profession kevin martin fabrique des
cartes de visite en bois à l'aide du
numérique il peut travailler cette
matière d'une manière innovante
là on a donc une représentation
vectorielle en fait des passages qui on
va être fait du laser et ensuite je vais
déterminé justement où est-ce qu'on
coupe où est-ce qu'on répondra ve avec
les différents codes couleurs les zones
noires seront découpés les parties en
rouge grave est connecté à la découpeuse
laser l'ordinateur lance la réalisation
du projet le résultat est obtenu en
quelques minutes grâce au numérique dans
l'idée que j'en ai c et intérêts un peu
plus justement d'éléments personnel et
personnalisé intégré justement par
exemple ces éléments scellement
informatique dans la nouvelles
menuiseries
c'est quelque chose qui pour le moins
est aux balbutiements marquage laser
impression 3d plusieurs machines existe
déjà
l'idée de kevin martin rassembler ces
outils dans un atelier de menuiserie
itinérant destiné à des particuliers
individuellement ou en groupes à travers
un système de réservation sur la base un
peu d'un camion tout le monde m'en parle
comme ça mais d'un food truck de la
menuiserie entre guillemets donc pouvoir
justement se rendre auprès du camion que
j'espère créer en fait une sorte d'
applications de géolocalisation et que
les gens souvent puisse venir donc seul
avec soi une idée à réaliser soit un
objet à réparer ou soir justement un cas
doit faire ou à personnaliser un atelier
au qui sera un peu comme on appelle un
été de recherche et développement mais
pour les particuliers c'est le principe
d'un fablab que je veux a fait
effectivement diffuser ce qui
actuellement beaucoup de choses qui se
fait justement autour de cette
thématique au niveau de l'écologie au
niveau du recyclage de la réparation en
cours de validation de la création de
son entreprise kevin martin va pouvoir
lancer sa démarche de recherche de
financement pour ensuite lancer sa
menuiserie itinérante
elle le premier tour des municipales a
lieu dans moins d'un mois à trappes le
maire sortant divers gauche guy
malandain et candidat pour un quatrième
mandat
elle et lui porte la liste est la gauche
qui agit soutenu par la république en
marche le parti socialiste et le parti
radical de gauche
il tenait sa première réunion en deux
campagnes mardi 18 février à la salle
pablo picasso reportage de grégory
canale trappe une ville qui le passionne
encore c'est ce qui a motivé guy
malandain 82 ans à être de nouveau
candidat dans la ville où il est maire
depuis 2001
pour son premier meeting de campagne à
la salle picasso l'élu a présenté sa
liste et les enjeux importants pour
trappe dans les années à venir
des thématiques sur lesquelles il
souhaite continuer d'apporter son
expérience et a besoin de continuer au
plan humain social éducatif urbanistique
etc
il a besoin de continuer de poursuivre
la politique qui a été menée jusqu'ici
pour pour terminer à leurs yeux terminé
veut pas dire qu'il faudra rien faire et
encore des choses qui me tiennent à
coeur des sujets comme l'enfouissement
de la nationale 10 les travaux ont
démarré et guy malandain veut les suivre
de près pour suivre aussi la rénovation
urbaine avec le secteur cités nouvelles
barbus et le square camus le pôle gare
également et le nouveau quartier
programmé à la halle freyssinet
enfin développer encore des projets
autour de l'éducation trap a été retenu
récemment dans le dispositif national
des sites et éducative il faut continuer
à approfondir tout ce que l'on fait pour
tirer la jeunesse vers le haut on est en
train de réussir concerne le modèle à
beaucoup je suis modeste en disant ça
mais de temps en temps il faut savoir
reconnaître ce que font les services et
bien aussi la population qui contribue à
tout ça moi je trouve que on arrive au
troisième mandat avec quelque chose
d'inespéré cette réunion était la
première d'un cycle de huit rencontres
avec les habitants avant le premier tour
des municipales fixées le 15 mars
prochain face à guy malandain trois
autres listes se sont également déclarés
pour le scrutin dans la ville et
justement parmi ces trois autres listes
déclarées attrape celle menée par un
groupe d'habitants citoyen en action à
la tête de la candidature jusqu'à
présent side
alim il a confirmé aujourd'hui à tv 78
qu'il ne conduirait finalement pas la
liste l'homme se retire de la campagne
pour des raisons familiales et de santé
et quitte par ailleurs le collectif
citoyen en actions pourraient tout de
même présenter une candidature au
scrutin dans la ville avec une autre
tête de liste
direction maintenant coignières
plusieurs enjeux se dégage pour les
élections municipales environnement
aménagement 1 du silo ou encore zone
commerciale à repenser présentation avec
michael niederau coignières une commune
de moins de 4500 habitants avec une
double identité urbaine et rurale
c'est dans cette optique que la ville
souhaite intégrer le parc naturel
régional de la haute vallée de chevreuse
coignières pourrait avoir un statut de
ville porte en 2023 intégrer le pnr
permettrait de valoriser son patrimoine
et notamment son église ainsi que ces
espaces naturels autre enjeu la
destruction du silo aux abords de la
résidence des acacias du centre
commercial le silo servait de parking
mais il a été muré par le bailleur en
les voitures ne pouvaient plus y garer
conséquence le quartier manque de places
de stationnement la structure devrait
être démolie dans les prochains mois
pour aménager un parking et un square de
zones commerciales sont également
repenser les portes de chevreuse et le
forum jb secteur est au coeur d'une
étude globale de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines pour
redynamiser cette zone commerciale avec
celle de paris ouest à maurepas une zone
commerciale traverser notamment par la
nationale 10 comme pour la commune de
trappes lax coupe la ville en deux
réflexion devrait être menée sur la
requalification une rénovation du
carrefour de la malle me donne est
notamment à l'étude et concernera
coignières la verrière et maurepas
enfin coignard a intégré 50 ans yves
hinant 2016 à doit aujourd'hui imaginer
ces futures collaborations avec les
communes de cette agglomération
ces dernières années la ville a
abandonné son projet de fusion avec
maurepas en 2018 coignard également mis
fin à la police municipale avec maurepas
après un an d'existence et la commune
n'a pas intégré le projet de centre
aqualudique avec maurepas elancourt et
je vous rappelle que dans le cadre des
municipales tv soit 118 en association
avec radio sensations vous propose des
débats entre les candidats ce soir
émission consacrée à guillon course est
à partir de 20h sur tv 78 et sur la
fréquence 98.4 pour radio sensations
yvelines
elle du sport avec le coup d'envoi dans
une semaine des mondiaux du cyclisme sur
piste à berlin
du côté de la sélection française on
retrouvera notamment un certain ryan et
la halle le pistarini montant qui vient
de fêter ses 21 ans tentera de remporter
sa première médias media médaille pardon
un mondial notre journaliste sportif
michael et demi d'euros la rencontre et
nous sommes ce vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à mes côtés à
ryan et la halle qui vient d'être
sélectionné pour participer à ces
championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste qui se dérouleront à berlin le 26
février à prochain raynal est ce que
vous êtes prêt pour cette compétition
oui je suis je suis prêt physiquement
j'ai fait une grosse grosse saison cet
hiver avec plusieurs manches de coupe du
monde
je me suis bien préparé et là je suis en
phase d'affûtage et je me sens plutôt
bien
est ce que c'est une surprise d'être
sélectionné ou est-ce que c'est dans la
continuité finalement baisse un peu dans
la continuité j'avais fait pas mal de
kirin ce set cet hiver combien j'étais
un peu récompensé de ses efforts là et
voilà je suis prêt
et motivés pour ce championnat alors
votre spécialité c'est plutôt la vitesse
là vous serez sur le keirin
est ce que ça peut nous perturber ou est
ce que justement c'est une bonne manière
d'apprendre une discipline comme vous ne
connaissez pas forcément à ça peut être
une bonne mère pour l'apprendre le
caring ça reste quelque chose d'assez
ouvert quand même un peu plus que la
vitesse individuelle et c'est un parent
est vrai ce faux dans le trajet beaucoup
d'expérience je pense à un niveau
mondial du coup année olympique en plus
de ça
savais tu que du positif que du bonus le
keirin s'est un petit peu particulier il
ya beaucoup de stratégies qui se met en
place pendant la course
quelle est votre stratégie vous en fait
ya pas trop de stratégie finalement
c'est beaucoup de bas d'instinct sur le
moment les opportunités c'est celle de
tout ça et c'est pour ça que ça fait un
peu la magie que kirin c'est un peu je
vais pas dire aléatoire c'est bon c'est
quand même les meilleurs qui gagnent
mais chacun a sa chance
alors ces championnats du monde se
dérouleront à berlin est ce que c'est
une piste que vous connaissez bien et
quelles sont ses spécificités
oui j'ai déjà fait une coupe du monde à
berlin
drôle une piste qui roulent très vite si
vite et c'est que les hydrates sont
assez courtes donc ce qui fait qu'on ait
beaucoup relancé dans les virages donc
ça va très très vite à chaque fois voilà
ce côté roland se relancer ça va aller
vite
c'est sûr que ça va aller vite et une
dernière vous avez a raté ses
championnats du monde cette année
j'imagine que vous êtes encore plus
revanchard c'est sa mort en char motivé
vraiment motivé pour y aller pour les
faire et voilà là je cogite tout à
l'heure je me suis bien préparé eh ben
j'ai hâte j'ai hâte d'être à la course
c'était une petite blessure qui vous
avait empêché de participer à ces
championnats du monde
est-ce que voilà ça a été difficile à
encaisser un petit peu vu que c'était
juste avant de décoller pour pour la
pologne mais voilà je suis passé à autre
chose je suis bien rentré depuis
et voilà de l'eau coulé sous les ponts
et mélenchon je suis motivé pour aube à
pau le coût pour un nouveau mondiale on
arrive forcément dans une année
olympique
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour être
dans ces jeux olympiques participent à
ces jeux olympiques est le plus fort
tout simplement l'équipe de france on on
est une équipe assez homogène avec un
très très gros niveau mais mondiale
finalement on en a beaucoup de coureurs
qui ont beaucoup de potentiel
voilà faut être le plus fort pour être
en dix ans soit une décision discutable
qu'est ce que ça représente pour vous
justement les jeux olympiques moi c'est
quelque chose de grand c'est pour que
c'est le pourquoi on s'entraîne pendant
quatre ans on travaille durement pour
cette épreuve reine des jeux qui
arrivent tous les quatre ans mixez voilà
c'est quelque chose d'assez ya pas plus
grands y a pas plus gros comme un
événement pour tout sportif je pense
et voilà c'est quelque chose que qui ne
touche à tout ça car vous êtes quand
même encore assez jeune
est-ce que vous misez sur ces jeux
olympiques 2020 à tokyo ou plutôt sur
les jeux olympiques de 2024 qui se
dérouleront ici au vélodrome national de
saint quentin en yvelines
ben je vais pour toujours à tokyo du
moment que la sélection n'est pas sorti
on n'est pas sortis on y croit tous ces
jeux pensait bonne stratégie à avoir
plus
tous y croient mais bien évidemment je
pense que toi déjà paris qui va très
très vite arrivé et je suis déjà motivé
une médaille c'est possible sur les jeux
olympiques
bon tout peu du manque au départ tout
peut arriver et on peut gagner
voilà donc on a tous deux bras deux
jambes et voilà c'est ton peut gagner là
la question qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter pour cette année 2020 que du
positif et du positif beaucoup de
réussite et surtout la santé
merci beaucoup rayonner la halle je
rappelle les championnats du monde se
dérouleront à berlin le 26 février
prochain il devrait être livré à l'été
2000 21 la construction du cinéma de
huit salles à maurepas va reprendre dans
les prochains jours annonce du maire de
la ville à grégory gars restiez sur son
compte twitter situé au village des
loisirs le chantier avait été stoppé
durant presque un an le projet a été
rachetée par le groupe cgr cinémas et
justement aujourd'hui nous sommes
mercredi c'est jour des sorties à cinéma
l'acteur originaire de trappes omar sy
partage la fiche du film l'appel de la
forêt avec harrison ford
alors qu'en avez-vous pensé bien patrick
jacques de dixmude et mathilde et demi
vous ont posé la question
[Musique]
le yukon est un endroit dangereux
on sait jamais ce qui peut arriver
je suis monté ici parce que je ne
voulais plus côtoyé personnes et puis
j'ai rencontré boc
je ne sais pas d'où tu viens
je sais où tu aujourd'hui bienvenue au
bout du bout du monde on va lui laisser
une minute je crois qu'il n'a encore
jamais vu de neige d'un film avec
beaucoup d'émotion de voir harrison ford
dans un rôle où il parle de beaucoup
d'émotion c'était c'était émouvant
c'était émouvant même les petites qui se
sont mis à pleurer c'est serrar est
vraiment magique
le voir justement parler d'amour par
rapport aux animaux de ne pas faire du
mal c'est c'est un autre registre et
c'est pareil rare de le voir avec ce
type de rôle les images le sont les
personnages la forêt en plus c'était
super
c'est plutôt à vue pour les enfants mais
les grands soit emerveillé aussi toutes
les aventures du début jusqu'à la fin il
magnifie que l' aventure humaine
l'aventuré animal quoi a
exceptionnellement marrison ford donc
voilà exceptionnel et vraiment je trouve
et enfin beaucoup touché c'est très ému
[Musique]
sutton top cette baisse
je n'ai jamais croire en quoi que ce
soit autant qu'il croit en toi
après le septième art place au 9ème art
l'espace richaud à versailles accueille
à partir d'aujourd'hui une exposition
autour de l'art de jacques martin et
plus particulièrement autour de son
célèbre personnage romain alix a créé en
1948 un mano varaldo vous emmène dans
son univers
bon nombre d'entre nous ont déjà lu les
aventures d'alix une bande dessinée de
jacques martin alsacien de naissance
l'auteur et dessinateur s'installe à
bruxelles en 1946 l'année de naissance
du journal tintin
il rejoint ensuite l'hebdomadaire et en
1948 apparaît alix pour les 70 ans du
personnage une centaine d'originaux de
jacques martin sont à découvrir à
l'espace richaud de versailles parmi les
visiteurs son fils bruno martin il a eu
le virus du dessin quand on était jeune
parce que voilà il semble était beaucoup
il était en alsace avec son père était
casernés à l'époque à nice après la
guerre des suites
il a commencé à dessiner comme ça et à
se raconter des histoires
jacques martin a fait des études de
dessin est remarqué par raymond leblanc
du journal tintin il a rencontré hergé
qu'il a engagées dans son studio il a pu
travailler aux aventures du célèbre
reporter mais aussi sur sa propre bande
dessinée il aimait jouer avec les
symboliques et avait des thèmes chers de
rêves prémonitoires les rêves qui
annonçait des catastrophes l'être humain
tout petits qui va être écrasé par sa
destinée est ici la précipitation dans
le feu donc à la destruction c'était
toujours des images très très dramatique
très anxiogène
jacques martin dessine écrit seule la
série de 1948 à 1988 il arrive très vite
à s'emparer de son personnage
alix pour le confronter au réel il est
mis en péril
ils ne gagnent pas toujours ses combats
il doit faire face au real il ya quelque
chose de la realpolitik dans le travail
de jacques martin son travail est exposé
à l'espace richaud 100 pièces originales
mais aussi des planches en noir et blanc
quelques dessins et des mises en couleur
originale de planches de bandes
dessinées à découvrir jusqu'au 19 avril
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]